As the Betancourt family heads
out to a party on Purge night,
you may notice a sign in their front yard,
noting that the house is armed by Sandin
Security. This little detail is one of many in
The Purge series that references James Sandin,
from the original movie. You may recall that Mr.
Sandin used his own company’s security system to
protect his family, and that didn’t work out too
well for him, and he was purged before morning.
Despite the supposed poor
quality of these systems,
they aren’t the only ones
to trust the Sandin brand.
DAVID: “State of the art Sandin Security.”
JOE: “Who’s providing the shell system?”
RICK: “Sandin.”
JOE: “The best.”
Even the NFFA once trusted Sandin to
install their system. It’s surprising
that Sandin is still trusted in The Purge
Season 1. According to the NFFA website,
their main competitor, G&D security, overtook
them after James Sandin’s passing, stating,
“we’re what Sandin promised to be, and wasn’t.”
The Purge Season 1 takes place in
2027 based on the dates displayed
on these security systems. We can assume
Henry’s signature on this release form
was a typo. That sets the season 5 years
after Mr. Sandin’s system was breached,
so I’m guessing improvements were
made to the company after his passing.
To learn all of the hidden connections in
Season 1 and Season 2 of The Purge TV series,
stick around to the end of this video.
I finally found a Purge mask that not
only doesn’t block my speech volume,
but also displays the goatee for the
world to see in all of its glory.
Welcome to Things You Missed. If you can’t
get enough Purge lore from the movies, there
is another 13 hours of content to consider, and
it’s called The Purge. Again. Let’s get into it.
The series opens with this shot of some
blue and yellow shower loofahs. Yeah,
apparently these things are called loofahs.
We later find out that these colors represent
the robe colors of an organization called
the Mercy cult. These kids are manipulated
into giving themselves up to the
Purge. Once they are old enough,
they graduate from these yellow robes
to the light blue ones that they die in.
Light blue has always been associated with the
NFFA and The Purge, but it’s not until Season 2
that we discover the meaning of yellow.
Yellow is the color of Remembrance Day,
the holiday that takes place 3 months later
to commemorate the lives lost on Purge night.
In the first episode, Miguel Guerrero
is looking for his sister at this
abandoned structure. This is actually
an existing location in New Orleans,
but the blue flowers and grim reaper
happen to work perfectly with the Purge.
As you know, the dystopian government party in
The Purge franchise is called The New Founding
Fathers of America, and the series features many
locations and references to America’s original
founding fathers who helped America gain its
independence in 1776. The finale of Season 1
takes place at Thomas Paine High School,
which comes up several times in the show.
The Stanton family lives on Jefferson St, named
after Thomas Jefferson. In Jane’s flashback,
we see that she attended Thomas Jefferson High
School. There’s also a street called Franklin.
“We have roadblocks,
[unintelligable], go across Franklin.”
...named after Ben Franklin. The classroom
seen in Episode 9 shows the constitutional
amendments and many of the Founding Fathers.
When Miguel and Pete search for the school,
they come across a map of Washington
Street, named after George Washington.
Likewise, in Season 2, Esme Carmona searches
Professor Adams’s house and there’s a framed
picture of the Lincoln Memorial, a location
also seen in The Purge: Election Year. And,
in the last episode of Season 2, reports go out
about illegal use of weapons in Washington Square,
another reference to George Washington.
If you’ve seen my previous Purge Things
You Missed episodes, which you should have,
you know all about the name Sabian. Every
Purge installment has a character named Sabian,
because they’re all written by James
Demonaco, whose trademark is to use
that name in his writing. In the series,
Sabian is mentioned in the first episode.
JENNA: “Oh and don’t forget, after you close
the deal, he’s probably gonna make a pitch
for us to become NFFA party members.”
RICK: “I know, I know, I’m ready for it.
I’ll deflect my way out of it. Now remember,
Billy Sabian closed a huge deal for his
start up here last year and he didn’t join.”
Another element we’ve come to expect in all Purge
entries is the inclusion of civil rights leaders
in the sets, as a comparison between America’s
Civil Rights movement and the mistreatment of the
poor in the world of The Purge. This time, you can spot
it in the hideout of Henry’s gang, where you’ll
see images of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr. and other
figures, as well as a quote by Harriet Tubman.
MLK and Malcolm X are quoted on the wall as well.
Another aspect we’ve become very familiar
with is the idea that each Purge is bigger
than the last. There are two Purges shown in
each season. First there’s the 2027 Purge.
“Prognosticators are predictinga
record turnout tonight.”
We only see about 90 seconds of the 2028 Purge,
so participation is not mentioned, but
the 2036 Purge continues the trend.
“Estimates came in already. Thirty percent
uptick from last year in every district.
Biggest Purge in city history.”
The 2037 Purge is no exception.
VIVIAN: “You ever seen crowds this big?”
CURTIS: “Never. This years tracking to
become the largest Purge we’ve seen.”
One of the big Season 1 plotlines
has to do with Jenna being pregnant.
There are a couple signs early on, like her
asking for Tylenol and ordering salt-water
instead of alcohol. That being said, I still
find this to be kind of a risky question.
CATALINA: “How far along?”
JENNA: “Is it that obvious?”
The second episode would be filled
with more connections to the movies,
as well as easter eggs connecting
it to other horror movie franchises.
In Miguel’s quest to find his sister, he
comes across a Triage Van, a concept we
saw more of further down the timeline in
The Purge: Election Year. There are a few
Election Year references in the series,
like when Miguel figures out his sister
is at the Carnival of Flesh, goes there and
hears this phrase chanted by the announcer.
“Purge and Purify! Purge and
Purify! Purge and Purify!”
That’s the same motto chanted by Edwidge Owens,
the main antagonist of Election Year. In Season 2,
there’s a cold open set in a company
meeting for The Merrymakers Mask Company,
and we see their logo strongly resembles
the style of masks used by the Russian
tourists in Election Year. We also see that Purge
Tourism trend in another cold open in Season 2.
Later on in Season 2, there’s also a part
where a van gets flipped over. I don’t know
if it’s a reference, but we’ve definitely
seen it all before in Election Year.
One of the trials Miguel has to overcome to get
to Penelope is an obstacle course known as The
Gauntlet. If the name sounds familiar, you may
be thinking of the 2016 Halloween Horror Nights
maze The Purge: Gauntlet of Fear, which
happened two years before the Gauntlet
appeared in the show. Other than the fact
that there’s actual danger in this Gauntlet,
it really does feel a lot like
a Halloween Horror Nights maze.
I would definitely be the camera guy wearing skull
makeup, and this is actually the stunt
co-ordinator of the show making a cameo.
There are actually a lot of funny
Purge groups in this season,
my favorite of which is these guys who dress
up as golfers for some reason. And when they
take their victim away, I love how he does
this giddy-up motion. Imagine being that guy.
The Purge is produced by Blumhouse,
who has always been known to put funny stuff
into some of their horror movies. One
example of this is Happy Death Day,
which is referenced in the entrance area to
Pete’s Cantina. Masks are checked at the door,
and on the rack, you can spot the Baby mask
worn by the antagonist in Happy Death Day.
The property is referenced again in
Season 2, where college students Ben
and Turner live in a frat house that seems
to be the same as the sorority house from
the Happy Death Day movies. I believe the
campus they attend is the same as well.
It looks like Ben’s dorm room even has a
poster for a similar mascot. In Happy Death
Day it was the Bayfield Babies, this poster
is for a team called New Orleans Baby Cakes.
There are plenty of other references on the
wall of masks throughout the night though,
like the sheep mask and fox mask, from the 2011
movie, You’re Next, a mask that was worn by one
of the Mercy Cult purgers in episode 1, the
mask of Godhead, from The Purge: Anarchy,
(more on that later). The mask shown on the
sign appears to be the same mask worn by Polite
Stranger in the original Purge movie, and that
mask actually appears on the rack in Episode 8.
It’s not just the movies that are
referenced though. This may be the
Finders Keepers app mentioned on the NFFA website.
Of course, I can’t leave out The First
Purge. I mean, I could, it’s my channel,
but I’m not going to. One of the storylines
follows a businesswoman named Jane,
who looks out her window and sees the
only building lit up on Purge night
is a bank. This is part of the idea
that The Purge is fueled by money.
Jane works at an equity firm, and in a flashback
to her job interview, she says the following.
JANE: “I’ve been following your firm since I read
a profile in Forbes back when I was an undergrad.”
This is the second time Forbes
has come in this franchise,
the first being on a police officer’s
name badge in The First Purge. Side note,
in Jane’s flashback we see her boss checking
her out as she leaves… but she never sees him,
so how does she have that in her
memory. It doesn’t make sense.
There’s another flashback in the following
episode, where Miguel and Penelope’s parents
are offered money to stay home during The Purge.
We can see the pamphlet that says Staten Island
experiment, this is the same pamphlet
we saw being handed out in The First Purge.
The First Purge isn’t the only movie
to have this struggle of classes.
Many of the entries make it obvious that the NFFA
is power because they are rich and The Purge is
all about making money. There’s actually a piece
of graffiti in New Orleans that says 2 MUCH THREL,
which is a slang term for a rich person, so this
is likely a form of propaganda against the NFFA.
We see how their brainwashing of
the American people has affected
people when Jane’s employee Alison
purges her co-worker in order to
ensure a promotion. I’m not sure
I understand the logic here. Sure,
murder is legal on this night, but wouldn’t
she still be fired for offing a co-worker?
Anyway, Penelope is taken away by a group
of purgers wearing nun outfits. Not sure
if this is a thematic choice, given
how some groups are starting to see
purging as a religious act, thanks to
NFFA propaganda, or just a result of
this show coming out in 2018 and creepy
nuns being really popular at the time.
What’s equally unclear is if the
anti-NFFA checkpoints set up in
the streets are related to the anti-NFFA
group from Anarchy. All I can confirm,
is that a couple of their members seem to
be wearing berets, as some of the Anarchy
resistance did. This headline seen at the end of
Season 1 is also familiar if you’ve seen Anarchy,
it warns of ‘Heavy Consequences
for Purge Night “Revolutionaries”’.
Oh, here’s another funny part.
“Wah haha hah.”
This is part of the aforementioned Carnival of
Flesh, which is also where you’ll find probably
the most hilarious mask in all of Purge. But the
Carnival may have more sinister affiliations than
you might have realized. The “O” in the logo is
a Celtic Cross turned 45°. This is a symbol used
by Neo-Nazis and Ku Klux Klan members. It’s
also displayed in the merch cart inside the
letter “O” in shopping. The carnival also sells
merchandise with KKK depictions. These racist
groups have been known to work with the NFFA
and take advantage of The Purge in the movies.
Penelope spends like three to four episodes
captive at the carnival thanks to her vengeful
ex-boyfriend Henry. Meanwhile, Rick and Jenna
escape after the Purge party they are attending
is attacked by revolutionaries. Then they get
held at gunpoint at home, by their neighbor,
Ross. This part actually drives me crazy.
It’s as if they don’t understand that there
can be conflict in a story without
someone holding someone at gunpoint.
Especially since we just saw like
3-4 episodes of that kind of tension.
And then if you’re going to do
it AGAIN almost immediately,
at least make it make sense -- like
she’s about to shoot this dude,
and the people standing behind him aren’t
even gonna move? What if she misses? What
if she doesn’t but she blows his brains into the
crowd? Or the bullet could go right through him.
Now before I move onto Season 2, there are
a couple things present in the background
all throughout Season 1 that I’ve yet to touch on.
What if I put the Plus-head mask on over the Angry
Abraham Lincoln mask… That’s kinda not bad!
The New Founding Fathers of America have
one practice that the originals never would
have been able to: using technology
for surveillance of the citizens.
JANE: “I forgot that you were
the eavesdropping type, David.”
DAVID: “You know I’m always
watching and listening Jane.”
We saw this more than ever in the previous entry
-- The First Purge, where I pointed out the eyes
that symbolize the always watching government.
The TV series gives us way more of that.
In the Betancourts’ house, you’ll
see large artwork in the hallway of
a human eye. When they return
home safely after the party I
noticed another eye up above a
painting near the front door.
In Henry’s apartment during a flashback, he’s
also got artwork of an eye, a very illuminati
looking one at that. An interesting note
here is that it says the word: Purity,
which may go along with that often
repeated phrase: Purge and Purify.
JOE: “I can Purge and Purify myself.”
Another note on this piece is that this
eye actually has a sword going into it,
a possible foreshadowing of what
happens to Henry -- his cornea
is permanently damaged in a fight with Miguel.
Jane’s Purge night is a crazy
one with many destinations,
one of which is a sexist human
art gallery held by her boss,
David Ryker. He too is the proud owner
of some artwork of a big human eye.
At the end of Season 1, everyone is
brought together by the main antagonist,
Joe Owens. Joe has been saving each of the main
characters, because he wants to put them on trial,
where they can either give a worthy
confession, or be purged by Joe himself.
Joe is very much like Jigsaw, specifically,
from the movie 2017 self-titled movie. Both
characters go around capturing people who
have wronged them, in order to try to force
them to confess to their wrongdoing. Also,
Eleanor is here, so, there’s that. Joe plans
his victims’ abductions by posting all
the information he has onto a big wall,
something we’ve seen in the Saw franchise in the
past, we learn he’s extremely smart and good
at math in a flashback and he even builds traps
that try to account for every possible outcome.
They even share the similarity of having
basic, non-suspicious American names.
“Oh my God, Joe?”
“Joe Owens?!”
“John? John Kramer?!”
Anyway, the reason I bring up Joe Owens with the
eye motif, is because he too ends up getting an
eye poked out. When it comes to Joe though, I’m
not entirely sure that he’s dead. In the final
battle, Miguel shoots his bulletproof vest,
shoots his knee and kicks him into the pool.
We never get confirmation that Joe died, and
I’ll circle back to that later in the video.
The last thing I have to hit
on before fast forwarding to
Season 2 is our crew reference easter
eggs. If you’re new to this channel,
filmmakers love to hide their own names in movies
and apparently TV because we’re very egotistical.
It starts at the rehab center Penelope discharged
from: Kantrow Rehabilitation Center is named after
producer Alissa Kantrow. There’s a list of
visitors at that rehab center that includes
first AD Paul Uddo and production accountant
Jeff Reynolds. The character Rick Betancourt
is named after co-executive producer and writer
Mick Betancourt. Pete’s Cantina has a poster for
a jazz show by Neal Orillion, which happens to
be similar to the name of the art director, Nealy Orillion.
David Ryker shows off an art piece that he calls
“an original Lemercier”. This is probably a reference to
executive producer Sébastien K. Lemercier.
During one of Joe’s trials in Episode 9, he
tries to get a confession from someone who picked
on him in high school, and shows a yearbook page.
Most of the other student names on this page are
crew. You can pause if you want to read them all.
Finally, there’s a flashback to the moment when
Rick and Joe had their falling out. The words:
McNight House are written on the
whiteboard in the background,
that’s a nod to cinematographer Kevin McNight).
The motif of an eye as a symbol for government
surveillance would continue in Season 2,
and there would be a lot more examples
-- almost as many as the amount of times
a character expresses their
dislike for this damn night!
“I’m gonna try to sleep through
this God-forsaken holiday.”
“I hate this night.”
“Must be the night.”
“It’s nice to officially meet
you on this sh**ty night.”
“I hate this night!”
“This night corrupts everyone.”
“This is their way of protesting this damn night.”
“C’mon, let’s go find a place to wait out the
rest of this f***ing night.”
“I just hate this night.”
“God, this night. This night is…”
“She knows what night it is.”
“This night has been a long one.”
“I think this night has
taken a toll on all of us.”
“Maybe he’s just having a bad night.”
“...but this night is relentless.”
“I hate this night.”
“This night just kind of makes me start
thinking about what’s really important.”
“A baby would probably make
this night even harder.”
“She hated this holiday, she wouldn’t be outside.”
“I’m done with this night.”
“God I hate this holiday.”
“I hate Purge night.”
The first eye motif can be found on the
necklace of Ben Gardner’s girlfriend,
Kellen. There are many instances of eyes being
present in the graffiti found around the city,
whether it’s a random piece of plywood, on the
bank, on a warehouse accompanied by the text:
‘I’m watchin you’, or in an alley. The presence
of these eyes play an even more important
role this season, where the plot literally
revolves around the NFFA surveillance team,
and areas with no cameras known as “dead zones''
are very important for the main characters.
The surveillance team is known as the
NFFA’s visual analytics department,
but most people have a different name for them.
RYAN: “You’re government.”
ESME: “Yes. I am.”
RYAN: “Which department?”
ESME: “Visual analytics.”
RYAN: “Eyes in the sky.”
Their office has computers with an animated
desktop background. The logo says: New Founding
Fathers of America -- established 1984. Of
course, they weren’t really established in 1984,
they were established in 2014, which you know if
you’ve seen my Horror History episode on them.
Later episodes do not contain this text. The 1984
is a reference to the novel, Nineteen Eighty-Four
by George Orwell, which is about a dystopian
future government who controls the population
through constant surveillance, much like the
NFFA, who always have eyes on their citizens.
In the second episode of Season 2, Ben
relieves his urge 2 Purge with The Purge
video game in a kiosk… in the mall. He exits
when another guy complains about how long he’d
spent in there and sees that he’s wearing
a shirt with three pairs of gorillas’ eyes.
Esme’s sister has a poster of
a peacock feather in her room,
which kind of looks like an eye, although
maybe she’s just a Jimmy Eat World fan.
Esme has a pillow in her own
home with a giant eye on it.
The opening of episode 8 shows
off a mask with one eye,
perhaps a callback to Henry from
Season 1. In the frat house,
there is a beer pong rules board which also,
for some reason, contains a pair of eyes.
The main antagonist of Season 2 is Ben,
who loses his mind after nearly getting
purged by a man in a Godhead mask. Many of
you wondered in my Anarchy video if this
is the same Godhead from Anarchy. That
guy was black, and this guy is white,
so I’m gonna say no, they’re not the
same guy, but I guess creating this mask
became somewhat of a Purge tradition, as
you’ll recall, we also saw one in Season 1.
Maybe the NFFA emblem posted
next to his bed is a clue that
he’s going to become evil. I’m not sure
why the Big Brain meme is here though,
maybe it has something to do with Ben being an
example of the findings of Prof. Adams’s study,
that aggression on Purge increases
aggression throughout the rest of the year.
“So those brain scans... they show that violent acts can light up the pleasure centers of the brain like a drug.
Especially those in the younger generation, those who grew up with the 28th ammendment.”
Bobby listens to an audio program from Bobby
Sheridan, the same speaker who inspired Joe Owens
in Season 1. At one point, he listens to the same
recording that Joe had on in the Season 1 finale.
BOBBY: “People will always surprise you when they
don’t want to die. But when you embrace the Purge.
When you commit to the healing power
of it’s violence. Anything can happen.”
Ben starts taking out victims off-purge, the first
of which is a farmer, who is eventually found,
but the cause of death is reported as heat stroke.
I was having a little bit of trouble understanding
why the NFFA would lie about this. It could be
part of their plan to give people the impression
that The Purge is working, that crime during the
other 364 days a year is down. But then why be so
strict about people whose crimes went past 7AM?
Maybe they only want to admit crimes occur when
they think they can catch the person in order to
make it look like nearly all criminals are caught,
and since Ben took out the farmer in the
countryside, there were no cameras on it.
This could also explain why they let him off the
hook after he admits to smoking marijuana. If the
public doesn’t know that a crime occured, it’s in
the NFFA’s best interest to keep it that way. What
I don’t understand is why that doesn’t make him
a bigger suspect towards being the campus killer.
The whole campus killer thing is honestly a
pretty big plot hole. Ben is playing video
games with his friend, Asian Andy. They’re
using an XBOX One. I’ll excuse the use of a
console that’s 22 years old in-universe, and
just assume they are fans of retro games.
What I can’t excuse, is the fact this
is where Asian Andy is taken out.
Ben lies about having been there. That means
there are no cameras in the hallways of the dorms,
even though we clearly see that there are
cameras on campus in the first episode.
TURNER: “This is awful. I feel
bad even taking a picture.”
Demonetized!
Speaking of that first episode -- I
think there may be a big callback to
the first movie. A man named Marcus finds
himself stranded outside during The Purge
and tries to get his neighbors to let him
in, but nobody does. It seems very similar
to the situation that Dante Bishop was in in the
first film. That’s not the only time that Marcus
seems to be connected to the Purge movie that
started it all, because his flashback scene takes
us back 14 years to 2022, the same date that
The Sandins had their home invaded by purgers.
This is also where we meet Plus Head. Kind
of a minor role to justify selling masks,
but I’ll take it. Plus Head can be
seen rolling with his buddy: Run Mouth.
Marcus has one more connection to the first movie
though. He has dinner with his wife Michelle,
in what they believe could possibly be their
last meal because it’s right before the next
Purge. She is playing Dubussy’s
Clair de Lune in the background.
🎵 Clair de Lune - Dubussy 🎵
MICHELLE: "So if this is our last meal."
This is the same song we heard at
the very beginning of the original,
which accompanied the montage of purgers
from previous years. Marcus and Michelle
both have the same dinner idea in mind that night.
MARCUS: “You did not cook. The night before Purge?”
MICHELLE: “We had sushi on our first date, remember?”
MARCUS: “Yeah, where do you think I
stopped before I came home?”
That one feels a little too close to the
anniversary shared by Nick and Amy in Gone Girl.
“It’s… we had that joke that our sex was too
good for ordinary, so these are 2000 thread…
We’re so cute.”
Marcus realizes that someone is
trying to purge him because of
a bounty posted on the dark web.
The site is called “Ivory Road”,
a parody of “The Silk Road”, which was one
of the first dark web drug trading sites.
“Wait, so how do you know about this?”
I know about that as a fan of the internet
and internet history, not as a customer.
Another important detail in this scene is the
calendar app seen on this phone, which is one of
only two a couple details that help confirm when
the season takes place. We know it’s before 2037,
because Ryan’s drivers license that expires in
late 2036 is still valid. But because it has to be
after 2032, based on how far back the flashbacks
go. That gives us a range of 4 possible years
where it could take place, and this calendar
only aligns with one of those -- it’s 2036.
Just don’t take the dates
of birth here too seriously.
This guy doesn’t look 55, but maybe
people age more gracefully in the future.
And apparently the headphone jack is
going to make a comeback and… a tape
recorder…? Seriously? I feel like the technology
problem in The Purge is never gonna get fixed.
But this Ivory Road account becomes something
that Marcus would keep coming back to in
order to try to catch whoever ordered
his hit. He puts up a post of his own
to try to find someone who can get him more
information -- one of the responses is spam,
advertising “Cheap Boner pillz the
NFFA doesn’t want you to have!”
The final storyline follows a band of thieves and
the NFFA agent whose computer screen
is home to even more Things You Missed.
The Purge is a night where all crime
is legal, but for whatever reason,
the first four movies and the first TV
season focus entirely on murder -- no
other crime is addressed, outside of just
a tiny side character here and there.
Season 2 totally changes that, making it one of
my favorite installments. We see bank robbery,
conspiracy, treason and hacking. That makes
it all the more disappointing that Season 2
is the only entry not to have a Blu-Ray
release. That makes it very difficult
to find little details, but with that
all being said… here’s what I found.
During the initial bank robbery scene, Tommy has
a shirt that says “break the rules.” He breaks
his gang’s code by going back for one more bag
of money as the sirens are beginning to sound.
This is what leads to him getting arrested,
because he doesn’t make it out in time.
He should have tried to make the argument that
his foot was lifted off the ground. I mean how
does this work anyway? Is it college rules
or NFL? We need some clarity, James Demonaco.
Anyway, Tommy goes to jail for 1 year before his
execution date on the next Purge. During his time
in the clink, Ryan brings him a book. It’s the
1844 novel, The Count of Monte Cristo, about
an innocent man who is wrongly, but deliberately
imprisoned. The book ends with one final message:
all human wisdom is contained in these two
words, 'Wait and Hope'. This was Ryan’s way
of telling him that if he holds on until Purge
night, they may have a way of breaking him out.
In the meantime, they also plan
their heist for the next Purge.
ZIV: “Our city attracts a lot
of people on Purge night.”
Although it hasn’t been updated in a couple
years now, this actually calls back to the
NFFA website, that was used to promote
each Purge movie. In 2014 for The Purge:
Anarchy iteration of the site, they did a
blog post about the top 5 Purge destinations,
where New Orleans ranked number 3 in the
country. I guess that held up for over a decade.
It’s actually referenced
again in the fifth episode,
where Miami and New Orleans are
hot tourism destinations during The
Purge, which also sets up the whole murder tourism
subplot in Election Year a few years later.
Part of Ryan’s plan for stealing the bank’s money
is to let the jackal’s steal the money for them,
and then steal it back later in the night. The
jackals are thieves that steal from other thieves,
so Ryan’s plan involves giving
them a taste of their own medicine.
When he and Esme look up the jackal’s
identities, I noticed some familiar names,
like Trent Sarreal and Sam Bogh. These
are also the names of Professor Adams
test subjects from her experiment about
the effect of purging on the human brain.
The photos are different though… and the
test subjects did not survive, so I think
this is a mistake, like they accidentally
used the name twice for minor characters.
Season 2 is not void of crew reference
easter eggs. Ryan has a flashback to his
days on the police force, where we we the
locker next to his is labeled Federico,
named after second unit director
of photography Federico Veradi.
During that same flashback, Ryan catches a
surprise out in the field on Purge night.
“Reynolds what the f*** are you doing out here?”
I already brought up Jeff Reynolds. He
was also a crew reference easter egg
in Season 1. Ryan’s director of training
at the police academy was Amy Krebsbach,
who was named after the truck costumer.
There’s also an article written about
one of Ryan’s heroic actions as an officer.
It’s written by James Crafton (that’s the
production secretary) and there are mentions
of names like Paul, Emily and Raul Uddo,
all probably family members of Paul Uddo, the
first AD who was also mentioned in Season 1.
The other article shown here mentions a gas
station incident, where Ryan is named again,
along with his superior, Andrea Ziv.
Her character is named after writer
and co-producer Krystal Houghton Ziv. The
article mentions a couple more crew members:
travel coordinator Callie Martin,
second assistant director Ben Ledoux.
Esme then moves onto a letter that
Ryan received from the mayor in 2010.
It’s signed by a Colleen E Moody,
who is also the script supervisor.
There’s one other crew reference
later on. Remember the part where
Asian Andy raves about Dr. Updale’s book?
ANDY: “I’m halfway through Dr.
Updale’s Foundations of the Experiment.
Unauthorized. I’m kind of a history buff.”
BONNIE: “NFFA History?”
ANDY: “Yeah. It was a best-seller.”
KELLEN:“Didn’t she kill herself after
creating the first purge night?”
ANDY: “No, that’s been
debunked. She died Purging.”
Not only does that explain exactly what
the NFFA told the public after the events
of The First Purge, but we see this book
throughout the series. First on a poster,
then Parker finds the book itself in
Ben’s possession, where we see the author:
M Martin, a reference to the
prop master Michael S Martin.
There’s also a poster that can be spotted
in town advertising for Purge: The Musical,
a story of good vs evil. I wonder if that’s
a sign of things to come. That’s right. You
heard it here first. The Forever
Purge is going to be a musical.
RYAN’S MOM: “Why aren’t you in school?”
RYAN: “It got cancelled.”
Well that one hit home a little bit HARD.
Not the first time the Purge
has predicted a disaster either.
When I did the Things You Missed
episode of The First Purge,
I pointed out this wall art of a boxer,
and explained how it represents the character
Nya. In the Frat House where Ben tortures his
fellow fraternity members there’s a portrait
of a football player in a very similar style.
Another callback can be seen when Ryan’s
gang busts Tommy out of captivity. It
seems the Mercy Cult bus from
Season 1 has been repurposed,
and is now used as the prisoner
transport vehicle on Purge night.
Season 2 comes to a close as Ben truly
becomes the new Godhead during the 2037
purge. He takes out most of his frat, but
Parker survives. As Ben is hunting him,
he’s hit by a car, and
wakes up in a triage center.
When he comes to, the first thing he sees
is a Jesus statue looking down on him.
Perhaps this angers him, because
he now sees himself as God,
he doesn’t want to be looked
down on by this religious figure.
BEN: “You’re just trying to play
God. But you’re not God. I AM!”
Marcus is able to sedate him and save the
rest of the Triage Center, but Ben survives.
In the final shots, he can be seen preparing
for another Purge. It’s an interesting choice,
and if my theory is correct, that means
both major villains from the TV series,
the new Godhead and Joe Owens, both survive.
As of now, The Purge TV series is cancelled, and
the upcoming movie, The Forever Purge is supposed
to be the ending of the series. How cool would it
be to see Joe and Ben, two of the most powerful
Purge villains we’ve seen so far, team up as
secondary antagonists in the franchise finale?
Whatever happens, I’ll be sure to cover The
Forever Purge here on Things You Missed.
So make sure you don’t miss it by subscribing
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell for all notifications and
I’ll see you in the next one. Assuming we both
survive. If you don’t want to get purged stay
home, but if you have to go out, wear a mask.